we know we know you've been waiting 15
years for the remake of Final Fantasy 7
and you can't wait to speed through the
whole thing to satisfy that insatiable
nostalgia of yours but take a deep
breath and trust your pal GameSpot on
this one because you're gonna want to
complete every side mission you can he
is why when Final Fantasy 7 released 23
years ago it spent a good chunk of time
in Midgar running you through an
overview of the world the story and it's
characters but because it was such a big
game you had to spread your one wing
eventually and fly away
relegating the city of Midgar - only
some late-game shenanigans this time
around the iconic locale plays a much
larger role in the story and gives your
party member some personal time to shine
in the remake after entering the sector
seven slums and completing some chores
with Tifa you can either go to sleep
like a total chump or become the most
badass murk on the market by helping out
some of the local shop owners and
Neighborhood Watch 35 welcome back and
you the new American town looking for
work right some of these tasks might
have you rounding up lost cats or
exterminating some where rats and while
this labor might seem menial in the
moment you'll find that the time you
spend one-on-one with Tifa talking about
your history together the state of the
world and avalanches roll in it really
flashes out her character's motivations
and life in the slums as her endless
onslaught of affection slowly chips away
at clouds cold exterior you see him
start to expose some of the
vulnerabilities we normally wouldn't see
until halfway through the original
culminating in an optional story
encounter that we won't spoil here but
if emotions aren't your thing and don't
worry we haven't forgotten about you by
completing these side missions you can
get your hands on some crucial early
game upgrades to your armor or in a
different part of town later on even
receive weapons you won't find anywhere
else at least that's what we found so
far
if the specifics aren't enticing enough
already then how about the thrill of
earning some cold hard cash
once you slay a couple of monsters for
the neighborhood watch you're gonna want
to spend all this Gil you're getting on
some new pieces of armor from the weapon
shop that provide bonus material slots
equip all the material you possibly can
because the only way they level up is if
they're slotted into your weapons and
armor while you're at it buy another
healing materia spell as well so you can
stack your party with options in a
struggle lastly
may find a slightly unsettling boy in
the streets named Chad Lee I know every
instinct in your body will tell you to
run away and not look back but believe
me he's got an offer you can't refuse
I mean maybe you can but don't chad Lee
gives you the assessment Iria and after
using the ability during combat to scan
for weaknesses
Chad Lee will develop new forms of
materia for you and later on provide you
with opportunities to fight summons in
VR so you can add them to your growing
stockpile the earlier you start helping
Chad Lee the faster you get access to
some super-strong material like synergy
or Shiva we won't spoil the next round
of side missions but rest assured
they're well worth your while if you're
trying to get your hands on a
fan-favorite weapon for watches cloud
wallows his way through the mid car gig
economy with a fan-favorite character we
hope you've heated our warning and if
not be sure to check out all our other
coverage of the Final Fantasy 7 remake
including things that we wish we knew
before we started playing the game a
tried and true lesson for life on the
ground floor am i right back to you all
now your money
[Music]